again i think he's surprised everybody
really threw the ball well he just
pitched good sliders this really makes
the pitches up early well escherman will
now face carlos correa curio on second
alvarez on first correa drills one down
the left field line fair ball headed
towards the corner yuli will score
easily jordan on the move he'll be waved
around and here comes the relay throw
not in time jordan alvarez will score
two rbi double for carlos correa astros
on the board first two to nothing two
out lightning by the astros and carlos
correa put together a pretty good at bat
kind of set up this pitch by fouling off
that fastball up and in and he got a
pitch that was hanging over the middle
you can see it just spinning over the
middle of the plate on our mattress firm
super bow as he shoots it down that left
field line
and you know what's great too with two
outs
base runners are usually off with the
swing so that's why jordan alvarez had
such a great jump and allowed omar lopez
to wave him home and score standing up
now kyle tucker returns to the lineup
for the first time in eight games the
0-1
tucker sends one into left field falling
quickly that's going to drop in for a
base hit carlos correa around third will
score astros doing a lot of damage with
two outs it is three nothing
welcome back tuck drop shot that's going
to feel good getting in on the action
immediately
got tied up a little bit with this
sinker on the inside corner
but does enough to fight it off and keep
it just in front of dj stewart out there
in left field and your pitcher this
evening for the houston astros is jose
or kitty it will be his 13th start this
will actually mark his 25th start in his
career on the season a 3.65 era the
opponent batting average at 220. he has
been effective at getting that fastball
change up curveball slider in the zone
he works fast mullins off second
one two and that's hit in the air pretty
deep to center it backs up straw on the
edge of the warning track makes the
catch mullins tags on his way to third
he'll get in
well ahead of the throw big out there
for urkini mullins led off the inning
with a double he's at third with two out
the o2
fly ball right field towards the line
tucker near the stands puts it away nice
catch by kyle tucker jose or kitty works
around a lead off double orioles failed
to score in the first three nothing
astros altuve on second brantley on
first julie might see a pitch here to
his liking the two one to guriel it's a
ball off the end of the bat shallow left
coming on stuart that'll fall in for a
base hit and to score altuve michael
brantley to third julie guriel two for
two with an rbi single as he parachutes
one in front of the left fielder stewart
it's now four to nothing yeah if you're
in the dugout and you see some of these
hits as it's a change up that he gets a
little bit too quick on it hits off the
end of the bat you're just saying heavy
you just want to turn that baseball into
a shot put and have it get down to earth
as soon as it can before the fielder can
get to it that's exactly what happened
it's been a great june for jose altuve
he's one for two here one out runner on
first the astros leap four nothing
drives one to left field back goes
stewart he is gonna watch this one go
jose altuve home run number 17.
astros have a half dozen it's six
nothing back in the swing of things
tenth home run in the month of june for
altuve as he drives one out to left jose
altuve picked this one up early out of
the hand recognized coming middle in and
he absolutely opened up and torched that
one to left field
398 feet
and welcome to the big leagues
right-handed knuckle baller mickey janis
he joins a
small
group of
orioles knuckle ball pitchers janice
today making his major league debut
33 years old
mark it down
it's a day that mickey janus will never
forget so janice will tow the rubber and
the first one he's going to face is your
don alvarez two strike pitch
he got him first major league batter
down on strikes way to go mickie janice
well the advantage is number one that
you don't see a wall whole lot and
another advantage is when you throw
strikes get ahead so well done
by mickey jannis carlos correa coming up
right field and deep korea
retired as it's caught on the track by
santander two down abraham toru want to
know the count runner going wins fires
down to second and tucker's out yeah
tucker first time he's been caught this
year he was five for five but austin
wins throws him out joe's trying to
rally with two outs and nobody on for
the third time in this game
sharply hit
down the left field line that will score
a run martin maldonado coming around to
score it is now seven nothing
michael bradley another two hit game
that shows leading seven and nothing as
we head to the seventh inning with
jordan alvarez you're not on an o2 pitch
drives one deep to right field and that
ball is gone
jordan alvarez
continues to hit home runs at camden
yards air yordon with his fifth home run
in six games at baltimore's home stadium
it's now eight to nothing here's abraham
toronto hits one to left field got into
that one pretty well dj stewart looking
up that ball's gone
three run bob abraham toro his first hit
of the night makes it 11 to nothing
astros how about that toro knows what
he's doing hitting right-handed off the
knuckleballer three-run jack that one's
spun also toro staying back on it and
driving getting on those legs and firing
that one into left field
that one went 417 feet one out nobody on
for chaz mccormick he entered the game
last a half inning and left
this ball hit into right center field
hit pretty well chaz mccormick he hits
it out chazzy fizz in front of friends
and family down from the philly area
hits one out in his burst at bat of the
night coming off the bench
and the astros now lead 12 to nothing
robel garcia at third kyle tucker at
second one out top of the eighth astros
leading baltimore 12 to nothing toro on
the ground great diving stopped by
wilkerson his throw late in to score the
run from third is robel garcia the
astros tack on another run
now 13 to nothing toro with an rbi
infield hit orioles with two men on and
that'll bring up dj stewart who's over
for three stuart waiting for an o2
here it comes
and that's the ground ball right side
altuve to the shortstop garcia there's a
double play for a three-game sweep and a
shutout for the astros 13 to nothing the
final score winning streak up to 10
games on the year
that is the astros third shutout of the
season
a three-pitcher combined shutout